[Music]
Katherine McNamara opens up about the
emotional experience filming the
Shadowhunters series finale I think the
biggest gift that we had was being able
to shoot a series finale you know we got
a - I think maybe two and a half hour
now that it's edited together movie
basically that's going to air at the end
of the season and it's it was so
gratifying and and I will be eternally
grateful for having that chance to
really say goodbye and them in the right
way and in a way that does justice to
this world into these characters that
we've all worked so hard to build it was
I guess my favorite part of it was
probably seeing not only the cast and
the writers and everything but our crew
as well who's been with us most of them
since day one really get to have a
little bit of artistry with it and let
loose because we're making it not only
for the fans but also for us to sort of
complete that journey and express for
one last time what we loved so much this
is who I am
join me I didn't steal anything I can
honestly say I didn't steal one thing
but I did I was able to take home a few
things I have a set of Clarice swords
and a stelae and a few pieces of
wardrobe but also our you know like I
said we're very much a family there our
camera crew has been with us our camera
operators and they're there folks have
been with us since day one and right
after we shot the last scene in Clara's
bedroom they took one of the you know
the wooden artists dummy molds that you
can kind of move about there was one on
Clara's bookshelf always and they all
signed it and gave it to me after we had
wrapped that set as they were tearing it
down and it's I have it on my dresser at
home now and it's just something that
allow me to keep with me always a
fashionista Katherine looks stunning
when she spoke with et at the daily
front Rose fashion la Awards daily front
row it's just it's a great outlet that
always sums up fashion both in their
ready-to-wear and the high-fashion side
it kind of combines everything and it's
one of those outlets that's always been
very kind to me so I'm happy to come out
and support I've always loved fashion in
the sense that it's a way to express
your inner self on the outside without
having to say a word and it's a way to
kind of express your whether it's your
mood or who you are as a human being to
the world in a way that's very artistic
and and you know since I was a little
girl I've loved playing dress-up but
I've always loved putting together my
own outfit and it's sometimes more it's
been more successful than others over
the years but it's it's always a lot of
fun and something I very much
appreciated
[Music]